based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your mark as you can see it's split up into two parts we
have our accuracy and our presentation on this side so we'll start off with the accuracy first
so your accuracy it's actually scored from a four so from the number four
you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern and then with that one any mistakes
that you make whether if it's a minor mistake get a minus of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get
minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the difference between the two so with a minor mistake
it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a outer block if it's not your shoulder height
maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1
you're supposed to do an outer block in the pattern but you forget and you say you do a
reach hand strike instead so that would be a major mistake so with a minor mistake let's say pattern
one for example there's 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20
patterns sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being it needs to be absolutely perfect to get
to not
get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say 15
mistakes so what would that be so we'll leave that there on this side and we'll come back and we'll
just calculate the squat at the end so a major mistake say you're supposed to turn to the left
when you turn to the right obviously we do want to try and avoid any of these major mistakes so
uh after we've done our pattern that's when we move on to the presentation side so the presentation
as you can see it's from a score of six uh this six is actually split up into three parts
so we have one two three here so with this one uh for a score of two is your power and speed
your rhythm is also a score of two and your expression of energy is also
scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power and speed so with this one
whether it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches anything you are that you do you need
to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so that it's one thing to have a very strong punch
or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and fast to get uh high in that in that category
and the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm uh when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm
to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way through it's not slow all the way through
it there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well so you do need to kind of work on your
rhythm and that's also scored out of two uh the last bit is your expression of energy so
what is expression of energy so that's basically uh how loud you shout so how much intensity you
have during your pattern as well so uh say you're doing your pattern really well it's really fast
and it's strong your rhythm is really great but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of
tell the judges can kind of tell well you're not really uh confident uh you're a little bit nervous
so that's what we need to kind of improve on on as well so i'll just come around to this side
so with this one for color belts and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently so
if you're a color belt you'll actually uh your average so where where the judges actually mark
you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so
say you did uh you did all right you did average compared to everyone else your score for one two
and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're less than average in the judges eyes you might go down
to say for your power and speed you might get a one or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might
even get a 1.3 or 1.4 so each individual uh category you need to obviously get as high as you can
Now, generally, depending on the competition, you will be scored from a 1.3.
So, 1.3 would be your average that you start from.
So, say your current speed was above average, you might get scored a 1.4 for now.
Say your rhythm was only about average, it wasn't amazing.
It might be just a 1.3, but let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So, your expression of energy, your average was 1.3, it might drop to, say, let's say a 1.0.
So, with this one, we'll come over down to this side.
So, with this one, as I was saying, it's a total of 10.
So, let's see.
So, for presentation, we had 0.7, 1, 2, 3.
So, you had a 3.7.
Let's see.
You made 15 mistakes.
So, with this one, obviously, don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes.
This is with the judges.
We have three judges usually at the panel, and each judge, obviously, is very subjective.
So, from their point of view, you might have made a lot of mistakes, or you may have made not a lot of mistakes as well.
So, that's why we have the three judges, and we average it out as well.
Okay.
So.
Say we did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
So, if they're all minus 0.1, it'd be 1.5.
So, you go 4.0 minus 1.5, which equals 2.5.
So, this would be your accuracy score.
So, with our presentation like before, we're saying we got a 3.7 here.
So, we add these numbers after the judges are finished scoring.
So, you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2, which is actually very good.
So, I'll just talk a little bit more now about this number here.
So, if you're a color belt, if you're a yellow or above, and you do your patterns, it's not uncommon.
Generally, for a color belt, the average is about a 4 to 5.
So, if you get a number between 4.5.
5 out of 10 for your pattern, that's actually generally considered pretty good.
So, anything above that, you can consider yourself pretty good.
If you're a black belt, the average would say, because we're talking here about the higher presentation as an average,
anything from 5 to 6 is actually considered pretty good.
And anything over a 7 is actually considered...
almost world-class.
So, if you get a 7 for any of your patterns, you generally need to pat yourself on the back because you did an amazing job.
So, we just went through our POMSE scoring.
So, just remember, accuracy is a 4.0, presentation is a 6.0.
Accuracy is judged during your pattern, presentation is after, and then we get the two scores that we add up, and we get that number.
So, with this one, obviously,
say I was judge number one, I would give you a 6.2.
There was another judge on the other side, maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than I did,
and maybe this one would be a little bit lower, it might be a 5 point something.
Another judge on the other side, they scored a little bit higher.
So, we'd get the three numbers, and then we'd average that as well.
So, I hope this helped you guys.
So, make sure you enjoy your POMSE competition.
I got it.
Anytime.
Make sure, obviously,
you...
record down your numbers as well.
Okay.
Okay, sorry.
So, plus minus count errors, got it.
Okay, so minor errors, major errors.
So, real time, you can score yourself.
Sounds great.
And can I pause the video?
No, not this time.
Okay.
Because you are, like, pretending you're a judge of yourself.
So, judges cannot pause that, so you just have to.
Yeah.
Sounds great.
And then right after the performance, it is power and speed.
Yep.
Coordination of rhythm and expression of interest, of energy, sorry.
Yes.
Yeah, perfect.
Sounds great.
And do I start?
Yeah.
It is perfect.
Yep.
Can I start it?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So, for the first three hours, we will have a mauling session.
Okay.
So, what we will do is, we will hear your voice.
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see what we can do, so please go ahead.
I mean, I can't.
You can say what you want to.
Okay.
This is a very worthwhile session.
All right.
Let's do it.
Thank you.